now this story one of the country's most
popular zoos is getting ready to say
goodbye to its giant pandas after more
than two decades the San Diego Zoo is
sending the last of its two giant pandas
to China at the end of its multi year
loan arrangement Jamie yuccas got a
behind-the-scenes look at the exhibit
ahead of the Bears departure Jamie good
morning good morning the San Diego Zoo's
giant pandas are part of a unique
breeding program to save the species it
was the first joint research program
between China and the United States when
it began in 1996 but now the most
successful breeding program outside of
China is coming to a close from kicking
back while munching on bamboo - watching
their roly-poly bodies tumbling on the
ground giant pandas are an iconic
attraction at the San Diego Zoo
but now visitors are lining up for a
last look at the adorable black and
white bears the black around the eyes
the white faces
emori a look at them and they look back
at you you're kind of like you know
something I don't know that's what
attracts us to them zoo keepers Dallas
Dumont and Cathy hawk have cared for the
pandas for years it was 1996 when by
Yoon arrived from China at the time
pandas were endangered so if Chinese
authorities asked the zoo to help save
the species from extinction
but when the breeding program began by
Yoon and her proposed mate didn't have a
magic moment lion was very much
interested in him but he had nothing to
do with her she flirted with him I know
how she feels she would roll in the dirt
and rub her face in the dirt thinking
she looks very pretty and she'd go
trotting up to him and he just go so
Barbara Joe Ranft the zoo's director of
reproductive sciences employed
artificial insemination it was
successful and researched to decipher
the mysteries of panda mating habits
began however the length of a pregnancy
remains a guessing game we've had
pregnancies reported as short as 85 days
and as long as a hundred and eighty five
days their physiology is still a little
bit mysterious
luckily by Yeun second suitor Gao Gao
want her over
pandas are born blind and deaf as Cubs
learn to climb it's not unusual for them
to take a spill something that keepers
discovered only when it first went down
we literally heard a collective from the
whole group in the Panda exhibit and
everyone was just beside themselves and
if he shook some shakes and stopped off
kind of looks around like oh I hope
nobody saw that and then back up the
tree
jolly Wu was their sixth cub CBS this
morning was first to meet the adorable
ball of fluff back in 2013 whether born
here or abroad all pandas belonged to
China the zoo says successful breeding
and an increased awareness of
conservation help boost China's wild
population of pandas to around 2000
downgrading the Panda from endangered to
vulnerable in 2016
building bonds of trust with the pandas
has allowed zookeepers to perform some
medical tests without anesthesia it's
also helping them crate train the pandas
for their journey back to China someday
their new home will be the Chinese
conservation and Research Center where
other San Diego pandas now live at 27 by
Yunes breeding days are over but that
doesn't make it any easier for those who
love her to say goodbye is it almost
though like this is your child and
they're leaving for college absolutely
particularly with by Yeun we've been
with every baby that she's had we've
held every cub that she's had so it she
is like our daughter our grandkids and
can't top that the panda exhibit will
stay up even while its empty San Diego
Zoo administrators are planning to
travel to China to continue negotiations
for new Cubs in the future because after
so long having pandas at the San Diego
Zoo has become as they say a bare
necessity don't done I forgot they were
on loan Jamie got they were on loan
that's all pandas belonged to China so
even the ones born here belong to China
and we've extended this program many
many times so it's time for them to go
back do you know what a group of pandas
is called I don't I just learned this
two seconds ago
I can't Betty it's called an
embarrassment of pandas like a gaggle of
junk or an embarrassment of riches thank
you nothing embarrassing about those
guys thank you thank you thank you